(players chanting)
- There's always pressure,
it's just, when do you tune it out?
Come on, I want you guys to go over it.
Counter, no counter?
It's not about what you're doing,
it's about how you're doing it.
So, whether that be me studying film,
applying to colleges, or
just studying for a test
like the SAT, it all
comes from your practice,
which you've been doing before.
We've done this hundreds of times,
ran this thousands of times.
The phrase that we use,
"Practice how we play,"
that's pretty much our slogan,
whether we're on the
field or off the field.
It all starts now, so
working little by little
to get to that goal, and we
practice, practice, practice
so that when the game comes along,
you already know what to expect.
You just know what you're going to do.
You can go out any day
and do the same thing
over and over, and it'll happen.
(inspirational music)